frédéric viale tête de liste de décidons
paris c'est la liste de danielle
simonnet la france insoumise dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france
un commentaire pour commencer on ne sait
pas si on s'achemine vers un second tour
finalement à quoi bon avoir organisé ce
premier tour c'est un peu la question
qui se pose en réalité puisque il ya
véritablement quelque chose d'anormal
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que au prétexte de sauver la démocratie
et de vivre la vie normal de la
démocratie le président maquereau a mis
en danger la vie des gens parce que
c'est ça qui s'est passé quand même
aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu'on peut dire d'un côté
que concerne les écoles et universités
les hôpitaux étaient enfin pas les
hôpitaux les universités enfin tous les
lieux publics et dans le même temps on
convoque 44 millions de personnes dans
dans les écoles justement c'est
totalement incohérent
il ne fallait pas tenir ce premier tour
est d'ailleurs la sanction elle est là
il n'y a plus de 50% d'abstention ni à
56 % d'abstention c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya jamais eu autant d'abstention aux
municipales en france depuis 1959
cette élection est à 7 ce premier tour
est une farce il faut arrêter ça il faut
maintenant prendre les responsabilités
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités et
qu' il y ait au moins un second tour
reporté en face à paray sa part est
absolument nécessaire dans les
circonstances actuelles
frédéric viale le gouvernement a dit
qu'il allait consulter des experts qu'il
allait consulter les chefs de partis
politiques mardi pour savoir justement
ce qu'il fallait faire dans les semaines
à venir selon vous il faut prendre des
décisions tout de suite il faut pas
traîner dans ces affaires là on est
effectivement dans des dents des
élections il va y avoir là maintenant un
certain nombre de discussions qui vont
se tenir par rapport à des résultats qui
de toute façon son revêtement fossé du
fait de l'abstention
donc il faut dire maintenant que
on reprend la question on refait les
élections plus tard alors effectivement
la question se posera de savoir si on
garde le bénéfice du premier tour ou pas
j'en sais rien je ne peux pas me
répondre là dessus mais en tous les cas
arrêter cette opération là parce qu'il
faut arrêter de mettre en danger la vie
des gens on ne recommence pas à à faire
venir 44 millions de personnes dans les
écoles dimanche prochain ça n'a pas de
sens dans la situation actuelle et c'est
même quelque chose qui est sur le plan
de la protection des populations
totalement inacceptable mais finalement
il en va de la responsabilité des
politiques qui ont agi en concertation
avec le gouvernement pour maintenir ce
premier tour notamment avec le président
du sénat gérard larcher
à qui profite finalement là ce premier
tour parce qu'on aurait dit oui à 6,6 au
premier tour avait été annulé c'était le
parti présidentiel finalement qui était
mise à mal et qui avait intérêt à ce que
ce soit annulée donc qu'ils aient acquis
profite finalement le maintien de ce
premier tour selon vous je pense en fait
que le président macron a fait un petit
calcul qui consiste à essayer de passer
par dessus les élections municipales
puisque de toute façon elle était pas
bonne elle ne serait pas bonne et était
prévisible qu'elle ne serait pas bonne
pour son mouvement politique et donc il
ya quelque chose qui nous sommes un
petit peu à l'oreille en dix ans mais en
fait ils vous lille a voulu faire en
sorte qu'on dise que ces élections sont
pas si importante que ça eh ben voilà
maintenant on est dans quelque chose qui
est quand même assez grave c'est que je
soupçonne quand même on peut soupçonner
le président d'avoir joué un tout petit
peu avec avec la démocratie d'une part
et avec la vie des gens d'autre part les
deux choses sont quand même assez grave
et on a entendu le président de la
république ce matin expliqué qu'il n'y
avait aucun danger
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez suivi
emmanuel macron a expliqué comment il
avait fait pour voter en disant qu'il
n'avait pas été testée puisqu'ils
n'avaient pas de symptômes
c'est une attitude présidentielle ça
selon vous dont les parler mais étant
donné la crise actuelle
non la seule chose qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait faire c'était prendre à bras le
corps l'intérêt général et dire voilà on
est dans une situation d'urgence
c'est son rôle de président la
république de prendre la décision qu'il
convenait de prendre
et plutôt que de se livrer à des petits
calculs politiciens de dire au moment où
il fallait faire c'est-à-dire il ya
maintenant plusieurs jours et voir une
dizaine de jours maintenant prendre un
certain de mesures pour arrêter cette
épidémie je crois qu'en réalité on a un
gouvernement qui n'a pas pris la mesure
de la gravité de la situation parce que
ça fait plusieurs jours qu'on entend
tout et son contraire que les choses
navigue qu'on a toujours pas
véritablement ce que dit effectivement
ce comité d'experts scientifiques
donc là maintenant il faut que les
choses soient prises un petit peu à bras
le corps et que le gouvernement prenne
ses responsabilités
au delà du gouvernement l'ensemble des
forces politiques merci beaucoup
frédéric viale d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur la france ce soir
merci